have you heard of the legend of question
six
it's the question that actually stumped
a field medalist
this is one of the hardest problems
ever well it's something legendary i
myself when i tried to attempt this
problem it took me a year
to solve this problem and when i finally
solved it
i'm not i'm not ashamed to say i cried
to put question six into context all
right i'm talking about an international
mathematical olympiad problem so
international mathematical olympiads is
the premier event for young people who
are really good at maths they haven't
gone to uni yet they're under 20.
and it's for young people to go and
compete on the international stage
right and they're fighting
for ultimate mathematical glory a team
consists of six kids from each country
these mathletes are required to answer
six questions worth seven points each so
just like the olympics they're held in a
different country every year they don't
do it every four years we need the
competition and we're talking about
somewhere between 220 to 260 students
come from all different countries and so
when you think about it this is the best
of the best it's about being able to
solve awesomely hard problems but
there's one epic problem
which means a lot to me because it's
from the maths olympics in my home
country of australia
so we held the math olympics in 1988 and
at that time there was one particular
problem it was the last problem of the
whole event over two days there's three
problems each and on the second day the
last problem was problem six
and this one went down
as one of the hardest ever for a long
time it wasn't surpassed now there's
actually been harder problems that have
come up recently but for a long time
this one was just amazingly difficult
and not only that it was like people who
did solve it were like
revered
so for the 260 odd people that competed
at this maths olympics
only 11 people solved it perfectly
and only one person solved it awesomely
and i have to say
terence tau was competing there and he
only got
one out of seven
one mark out of a total of seven for
this problem which means he didn't get
it right and terence tau went on to win
the fields medal in 2006. he's awesome
and he's australian can i just say that
please and he's someone and he's from
adelaide where i'm from as well yeah and
me and you brady i didn't know whether
we could mention that let's actually
let's actually cut cut terrance tower
some slack
the feels medalist the guy who's like
coming close to solving the twin prime
conjecture it's actually pretty awesome
because he was only 13 years old and
that's young
well he holds the record as the youngest
person to ever have won a gold medal at
an international match olympics so it's
pretty good but he still didn't get the
last one right terry towel was a toddler
when his parents noticed he had a gift
at a family gathering they found their
two-year-old giving older children a
maths lesson i mean these are problems
that you don't find in a maths book
there's no you don't look in the back of
the book for the answer for these
problems these are really hard problems
and and in a way they're actually
designed to kind of throw you off if you
know high school maths too well so say
if you really know how to solve
quadratic equations
and you see something that looks like a
quadratic equation it almost like throws
you down the wrong path it's almost like
you're at the international math
olympics
question six
was pretty special it was come up by
this crazy hardcore west german guy at a
time when there was a west germany and
he submitted his question to the
mathematicians who are in charge of
selection they're given six hours to
solve question six these are the experts
like test test driving it they're test
driving yeah they're test driving
they're going to see whether it's going
to make the cut you know because like if
it's too easy
turf that right
well guess what
they couldn't solve it after six hours
question six
after six hours
still stood
yeah
so you'd think hey this is too hard
what do they do
they have the courage
to submit it they put it on the test
they put it on the tests and in the
original copy they actually put a double
asterisk next to it just to make sure
everyone knew this was hard so don't
waste your time on it well not
necessarily don't waste your time just
don't beat yourself up if you can't get
it and so here i've actually got a copy
july 16 1988 so it's held over two days
this was the second day and it was the
third question on the second day so
therefore it's question six
now if you have a look here the time
to answer all three questions four and a
half hours
so that means on average you had
90 minutes to solve
this problem
and if you can't work out that was 90
minutes i think you're going to struggle
with the whole exam
given the fact some of the best
mathematicians in the world were given
six hours and they couldn't solve it
they gave students
90 minutes on average maybe it could be
more maybe you finish these ones really
quickly and then you just sit there
sweating and if you have a look at it
it's the shortest one on the page look
how tiny it is it says let a and b
be positive integers such that
a times b
plus 1
divides
a squared plus b squared show that a
squared plus b squared divided by a
times b plus 1
is the square of an integer
it's not even simple to explain i mean
they have actually covered up
part of what what you need to understand
okay let me just write it out for you
okay so so what this says is that
first of all a and b
uh can be
elements they can be 0 1 2 3
they can be any whole number including
0. let's stick them into this equation
a squared plus b squared divided by a
times b
plus 1. okay so let's actually do a
little bit of a chart for this so
possibly it could equal a fraction so if
it does equal a fraction
the question says
no one
cares really question six doesn't care
but
if it just so happens
that once you divide
a b plus 1 into that and you get a whole
number it then says oh that whole number
will also be a square
it means that it will be
something to the power
2. like 25 yeah 25 36 49 121
it'll be some whole number multiplied by
itself so only if it's a whole number it
actually will also be a square number so
i suppose i suppose one way of saying it
is that
the only solutions to this
given whole numbers when you're sticking
whole numbers is are fractions
and squares
and the thing is is like
why squares perhaps we should find out
so there's the history of the problem
explained and by now i hope you've
cracked out your pencil and paper to try
it for those wanting the solution a bit
sooner the next video will be posted on
our second channel number file 2. all
will be revealed there in the meantime
our thanks to the supporter of this
video the great courses plus this is a
huge online collection of video lectures
from world experts on every topic under
the sun you can become a master of
everything from photography to maybe the
rubik's cube seriously a 46 minute
lecture from the excellent art benjamin
on solving the rubik's cube plus some
mathematics on the side most people find
it a hopeless task to bring the cube
back to its proper order i might finally
get this thing solved plans start from
14.99 a month but you can sign on for a
free one month trial at
thegreatcoursesplus.com
numberfile there's the address on the
screen or you can click on a link i've
put in the video description again our
thanks to the great courses plus and if
you do browse through their 7 000 odd
videos make sure you check out the
rubik's cube one that's the one i'm
about to watch now amazing secret
solution to solving this problem
is actually a beautiful piece of
observation
it is